the mention of the Patriots is relevant
to today's draft which is moves the
Patriots should make to entice hashtag
Tommy to stay put Chris you've got the
trivia quiz here we go
Michael Florio Julian Edelman led the
Patriots and catches and receiving yards
last year who was second in both it's
the same person who was second in
receptions and yards behind Julian
Edelman rockier brain wrack your brain
Brooke and Manu I walk to school with
the flashlight and it was two hours
behind
um my gosh who was the guy who was the
room when they were rookie there was a
rookie hmm there was what was his name
Nikhil Harry it's not was it him nope
who was it
James white running back it was actually
right it was actually too easy you
probably didn't even think you said you
set me up for it you jerk during the
break by saying oh you'll never get this
one so I'm thinking it's gonna be some
convoluted complicated question alright
go ahead we showed literally his
receptions earlier in the show on a
graphic so I was I didn't want to make
it the camera not I tried bull crap you
might look at your computer or your
phone to text you're not looking at the
monitor you're right I know that there's
the graphic again just so you want to
see it okay we gave you the answer
during the show start paying attention
to the show yeah oh yeah you remember
the show get a good job okay Odell
Beckham Jerry's not on their first pick
I mean if you want to keep Tom Brady
damn what a shot way I am stuck you're
stuck I am stunned your stock don't know
I don't know which fan club you should
be the president of you're the president
of one of the vice president the other
Aaron Rodgers Odell Beckham jr. yeah you
would lose your mind if they ever ended
up on this oh my gosh please please
Green Bay trade and get Odell Beckham
jr. so I could just go all in on my
fandom okay but yes I mean hey we all
know I'm having a little fun I don't
think this is actually realistic I don't
because I think Cleveland's going to
hang on to
jr. but I think New England probably
calls calls Cleveland to see what what
what it might take to get him you know
and I don't think New England's the type
of team that's gonna offer up anything
crazy cuz we've heard the Browns even
say that's something crazy maybe they
would but it just I say it because we've
heard history between both of these
teams and well you know I know that New
England likes Odell Beckham jr. a lot
and Odell is expressed a lot about how
much he respects New England and Tom
Brady and all of those things so that
would be a move where Brady would go hmm
okay see you San Francisco see it says
he sightings I'm staying in New England
and going to win my seventh I I don't
think it would work for Odell Beckham
jr. in New England why I reminds me of
one Chad Johnson went to New England
because you have to leave your entire
individuality at the door and the first
thing he'll hear from Bill Belichick if
Bill Belichick even wants him yeah yes I
don't want any more of this crap with
the kicking net with the watch you wear
I mean all that stuff that Beckham has
used over time to express himself is
gone it's over it's done you are now a
cog and a machine that should not in any
way stand out and I don't know that he
can conform to that well maybe winning
maybe winning I'll help him conform to
that but I don't know that he can
conform to it yeah I listen I I
understand the questions I do think
there's a little more room for
characters up there then maybe we give
credit I mean come on they had you know
one of the biggest do feeis guys we've
ever seen in Rob Gronkowski but I
understand your concerns that's it's
definitely real well and I think part of
it is Gronk was able to stay doofy even
when he was getting the stink-eye from
Belichick I don't think Beckham will I
think Beckham will take it a lot harder
he doesn't that kind of guy you know he
there's a high degree of emotion in him
and and I'm not saying that a bad way
and you know Gronk gets a dirty look and
he kind of laughs and chuckles and I
don't know that obj would respond that
way alright for me job number one get
Dante's car Nekia to unretire again he
was with the team at the Scouting
Combine that does not mean he is Unruh
tiring again but he is retired for now
he is the
master of offensive line play and even
with him last year the offensive line
wasn't very good could you imagine how
bad it would have been if he wasn't
there yeah yet scar neck ear to stick
around that if you can go to Tom Brady
with that on Sunday when it's time to
try to negotiate a deal that is a major
factor in him staying put Wow I'm that's
that's pretty big-time by you there I'm
really that was a good call I mean I
wasn't expecting that sandbag well I
just thought you're gonna hold that went
to round three I wasn't well I wasn't I
wasn't thinking you would go there I'm
not even a lot I didn't write him down
either I just that was a good pick by
you I hear you know that would certainly
make him feel a little bit better
because you're right scar Nekia is him
you know Mike Munchak out in Denver a
few other guys they really jumped out to
me scar neck Ian Mike Munchak with the
two best offensive line coaches I was
ever around they were phenomenal another
level and that would be a good a
quarterbacks best friend all right my
next one I would call the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers OJ Howard need to tight end
hey you know Oh J Howard's this freak
freak of nature athlete who for whatever
reason just has not seemed to click in
Tampa Bay we've seen moments here and
there where we go oh there's the guy
that was the first-round pick and a
freak of nature but as we talked about
earlier in the show I mean New England
you know there's a need at the tight end
position
you know the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and
you know and and Bruce Aaron not
necessarily famous for getting the tight
end the ball that way either
New England does have a spot for that
and I think this is a offense that has
more ways to get the tight end the ball
in the drop back pass game than any
other offense in football and that's why
it's so important for them to have that
position and why you're hearing those
rumors and I think that would be a great
target for Brady to feel comfortable
with down the middle next one from me
and I was gonna hold this to around
three but I got a feeling that you're
gonna jump on it because what we talked
about trading for ohto Beckham junior
traded for OJ Green trade Raj green
rather trading for Stefon Diggs they've
already given up a second-round pick to
get Mohamed Sanu yeah I don't think
they're gonna start dumping a lot of
draft assets into another established
receiver use those draft assets instead
on rookie receivers that you can develop
I say bury the hatchet with Antonio
Brown bring him back No
because I think that they that you know
look I think right now no one should do
business with Antonio Brown until he
shows that he has made meaningful change
but it's obvious that Brady loves the
guy he got a heart emoji tweeted in his
direction from Tommy over the weekend so
Brady has the connection to brown they
didn't get a chance for it to really
flourish I don't know what the debt
Antonio Brown is going to have to pay to
the NFL for the multiple personal
conduct policy investigations that are
still pending but it's clear that Brady
loves the guy I don't think he's just
being nice
I think he'd love to have him back we
got a glimpse of what they could do
together you want Tom to stay you get
Antonio Brown back under contract and I
don't think their desire to keep Tom
Brady is strong enough that they would
want to bury the hatchet with Antonio
Brown but if you want to keep Tom I
think that's a way to do it well it's
certainly yeah I would think that would
open Tom's eyes for sure he does seem to
have some affection for Antonio Brown
and hey listen we both know a lot of
people that love Antonio Brown when
you're around the guy he's he's got a
great way about him but as we both know
it's we've seen a lot of you know weird
turns and things in his life over the
last two years and yeah I don't know I
mean really right now with where it's
it's in Antonio Brown if you had a bet
money is he in the NFL next year
like what's the Florio meat and pasta
bought meat and pasta gut say my gut is
that he won't be yeah because I don't
think he'll ever do what he needs to do
to get back I agree he'll never he'll
never submit to what he needs to submit
to to get back right it's not gonna
whatever has gone wrong for him is not
gonna go right in time for him to play
this year that that's what I believe in
I hope it does yeah hope it doesn't hope
he gets the help he needs and I hope he
finds his way back to his chosen
profession if I have to predict though
I'm saying it's not gonna happen yeah
yeah I'm with you I kind of have the
same feeling there all right I'm gonna
go with the guy we opened the segment
I'm going Stefon Diggs you know one I
know that New England love Stefon Diggs
coming out in the draft out of Maryland
so there's always been a love affair
there too I look at that and Stefon
Diggs and go man you know that is a
perfect fit for that offense you know
he's got a lot of Julian Edelman Wes
Welker type qualities where he
can work the middle of the field all
those option routes those jerk routes
these routes where the receiver needs to
know the coverage and be on the same
page with Brady dig certainly capable of
doing all that but also has the speed to
line up on the outside and just beat
people deep got great versatility within
what he can do at the wide receiver
position he really he could be Julian
Edelman except he could be more of a
threat on the outside to beat people
deep and I could see that and again I
think Minnesota I just think this is one
of those players and teams and
situations where you know I'm gonna keep
my eye on this player in this situation
as we continue here through the free you
know through free agency just because
the amount of money he's making you know
their salary cap issues they're in
Minnesota we know they need to build
some depth on their football team and
they have some other guys they'd like to
sign where yeah I would not be shocked
if he gets dangled out here by by trade
what happens the first time Stefon Diggs
pallets and Bill says you don't like you
get the hell out of here well you know
that to me is the one thing you know
again those are scary like you brought
up with Odell Beckham jr. and all that
but the one thing you see with a lot of
those guys when they do get theirs man
they change in a hurry and it's just
that place has a special way of
conforming you or non conformal you're
gonna sweating you out right exactly
right right so you you know in Chris
Wright I don't think you can hinge draft
pick risk on the possibility that it's
not gonna work you know not significant
draft pick risk because there is a
chance it's not gonna work there's a
chance it's gonna be like Reggie Wayne
remember Reggie Wayne one training camp
this isn't fun I'm out of here
right Chad Johnson was never the same
guy again I mean the list goes on and on
and that's a heck of a risk and I love
Stefon Diggs but we've seen it from time
to time you gotta know how to handle him
and he's gotta know handled how to
handle the situations very different
form in New England ya know that's it's
real you're right but we've also seen it
work too when they've traded and got
guys any branded cooks and Randy Moss
and other guys have all found ways to to
conform as well but yes it's risky it's
certainly a different culture a
different way of life and you do lose a
little bit of your you know yeah your
personality and your
that way when you go up to New England
you have to sacrifice those type of
things to win and win the Super Bowl and
that's just the way business is done up
there all right last one for me because
again everyone hears is trade trade
trade it is already giving up a sixth
round pick for Mohamed Sanu a second
round pick not six second they're not
going to trade any more assets for pass
catchers why do you need to trade
anything when there's a guy on your
reserve retired list you just need to
convince him to put 30 pounds back on
that's his but back in uniform bring
back brung bring back brung you want Tom
Brady to stay bring back Grunk listen
it's rarely a landslide it's it's it's a
lamp you die I don't even talk about who
wins or loses as much as we used to
you're done Grunk
I could beat Gronk in an arm wrestling
contest right now whoop-dee-doo I think
I could take him the bench press - hello
pay-per-view I bet you can't bench under
25 pounds 20 times like I got this
Carnegie in the first round he's a
hundred and forty-five years old I mean
holy cow just joking done he did he did
he did walk to school with a kerosene
lantern he definitely did all right as
you go draft it was a fun Drive when I
say that because I it was I don't want
to sound like big cat because it gets so
old that I dominated you now I dominate
I did dominate you yeah I kicked your
ass oh I did
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports